chris i have to ask you i'm a big fan of
your directors on dungeons and dragons
and that is the reason why i am actually
really looking forward to the movie uh
the filmmakers and obviously your
performance but what can you do
but i mean but being honest like the
director is obviously very important to
delivering what you're gonna see um what
can you tease people about the movie
because it's been sort of quiet and i'm
really looking forward to it oh man well
what i will say is we had a hell of a
fun time making it there was a lot of
laughs um
[Music]
the way that i've been describing it
it's like
game of thrones
mixed with a little princess bride
just a smidge of um
uh holy grail
[Music]
gosh
yeah it's somewhere in that ballpark
it's a lot of fun it's got a lot of
thrills it's poppy
it's 80s heartfelt there's like a bit of
goonies in there
um
uh
my character is uh
is uh
he's uh
he's the ultimate party planner
i think it's gonna be really good i mean
who [ __ ] knows but i think we got a
good shot and john and john are
our killer guys they know
they know comedy and they know heart and
we had a great cast and we had a good
time making it and that's all you can
ask for
you